what historians and economically
economic historians talk about is this
idea of the leading sector how do you
think about this transformation how is
it not just that smooth inevitable
looking curve and what the idea they use
is this idea of the leading sector that
there's one particular area of the
economy that is so profitable that it
pulls and so big that it pulls everybody
else in its wake bringing about new
opportunities for growth new jobs wage
growth everything and first in the
pre-industrial capitalism of the 18th
century you have cotton sugar and
shipping then industrial capitalism
wheat railroad steel and then the 20th
century cars and chemistry aerospace and
electronics
this shouldn't be that hard this isn't a
crazy idea this is what we see every day
i mean after all how many of you have
blackberries
so retro did you come here to fixie i
bet you did yeah so the idea
so i think that
this is a basic idea that when a product
comes out there's tremendous
opportunities for profits
it grows over time and then as it
becomes a mature industry it falls and
this isn't true just of particular
products like blackberries but entire
industries so over time the technology
becomes well known and it becomes a
commodity industry this is just
normal ways of thinking
now
this leading sectors are very important
because first of all i think it should
be obvious that aerospace is not obvious
that most of us
cannot just walk outside and be like oh
let's build a plane
cool
um it's actually super hard it's very
hard to build a railroad it's very hard
to imagine an industry as complicated as
the electronics industry and so this
transformation
is not obvious what that next leading
sector will be
and yet
so far
we have been able to figure out what it
is
finding that new
industry that allows us to
bootstrap ourselves into the next level
of growth
but finding that next sector has not
been obvious in the past as it was not
in the 1930s as it was not in the great
depression
when there is a failure to find that new
leading sector
when capital does not find its way into
a sector that can pull along millions
and millions and billions and billions
of people
we have a depression when capital can't
find that place to earn that profit
we have a depression and that's what
happened in the 1930s if you look
closely at the industries of the 1930s
after the initial crisis the crash of
the stock market in 29 followed by a
crash in the housing market a couple
years later
all the cutting-edge industries
like electronics and aerospace
they were fine within six months
but they were this big they were this
big
more people in the u.s worked in candy
manufacturing
than in airplanes in the 1930s
and all the big places where we invested
all our capital all our biggest
employers sorry all our biggest
employers like cars
just wasted away
the stagnation was a crisis of the
failure of capital to get into these new
industries
where is capital in america in the 1930s
it was in banks and capitalists like
amadeo giannini the founder of bank of
america
i want you to notice that he is not
skiing
he is not smiling
he is very he's a very nervous italian
guy
he does not know what to do with all his
money
this is a letter
more than any graph i think reveals this
anxiety this is a letter from the
citibank archives
between the head of citibank would now
then known as national city bank and the
bank of america
my dear ap
i want to give you a short report of
conditions here and put before you the
city company situation
our excess reserves are very big
it's almost impossible to find any use
for money in credits that we're willing
to take and the rates are terribly low
too much capital
nowhere to put it even though millions
are out of work
and these new industries that we now
know
our great investments
or that are capable of producing
millions of jobs
don't have capital to grow
i want you to think about that
[Music]
you